the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thursday and
house of the dragon video one thing i
want to say right at the beginning of
this video is how much i like the
episode it was without a doubt my
favorite episode of the season thus far
it feels like house of the dragon is
really starting to find its footing
after watching this episode i find all
of these relationships far more
interesting now in fact my own
relationship with these characters is
different i find that i'm now far more
invested in these characters all of the
actors were incredible in this episode
so let's dive into the scene so i can
show you exactly what i mean we
immediately go inside storm's end a
location we have never been inside
before this is the ancestral seat of
house baratheon and it's also one of the
mightiest fortresses in all of westeros
since this was the official home of
robert and stannis baratheon we have
heard a lot about storm's end but we
never actually went inside of it until
now the episode begins with renera
sitting in the high seat alongside lord
baratheon as she greets several of the
lords of westeros who want to win over
her favor and hand the first man we meet
is a lord dondarrion whose name you
might recognize from game of thrones as
he is an ancestor of lord barack
dondarrion the same man who was brought
back to life again and again by the lord
of light then we meet a member of house
blackwood a name you might not recognize
from only watching the show one
interesting thing i should mention about
house blackwood is their relationship
with house targaryen they actually come
together and create one of the most
interesting characters in all of a song
of ice and fire
bloodraven who is also known as the
three-eyed raven in game of thrones is
made up of ice and fire like jon snow
the three at raven's real name is
brendan rivers his father was aegon
targaryen the fourth of his name and his
mother was a lady known as melissa
blackwood now since his father was a
targaryen he had the blood of the dragon
and since his mother was a blackwood he
also had the blood of the first men
something they did mention in this scene
the blood of the first man still flows
in their veins
when these houses united brendan rivers
also known as bloodraven or the three-ed
raven was made of ice and fire one of
the main reasons why i think he was such
a special character i like how this
scene shows there is a member of house
blackwood with their eyes already set on
someone from house targaryen eventually
these houses will unite and make magic
now much of this episode will focus on
renera and her search for a husband
shortly after renera gives the room a
vibe check she's dissatisfied with who
they have to offer so she heads back
home for the city now before ronera does
leave storm's end we do see some blood
get shed inside of lord baratheon's hall
this is interesting because something
like this will happen again in a later
season only next time lord baratheon
will say i don't want any bloodshed in
my hall forcing a certain character to
leave and get his vengeance elsewhere
let me just leave it at that because it
will be a very big scene when it does
happen on ronira's way home we get our
only glimpse of a dragon in this episode
when damon and karaxis say hi by
brushing up against the ship as you
could see in that scene ronero was very
happy to see that damon was back in the
city later in this episode we will see
just how happy she really is now back
inside the red key everyone seems really
nervous about damon's arrival they're
all whispering and shuffling around
worried about what will happen next not
only because they know viserys has been
having issues with his brother but also
because damon is very unpredictable they
don't know what's gonna happen once
damon and vasara see each other again
remember it has been four years since he
was thrown out of the city again we see
renera's excitement all over her face
her father on the other hand is doing
everything he can to hold frame he
doesn't want to look weak in front of
everyone else
viserys is expected to have some harsh
words for his brother who rolls up in
there all nonchalantly with a crown of
his own on his head this is seen as
another great sign of disrespect to his
brother and king as you all know he
knows exactly what to do to get a
reaction out of viserys not only does he
have a crown of his own on his head but
he also already has a weapon drawn in
hand
that is a threatening gesture that
doesn't go unnoticed i think it's funny
how the lore commander the kingsguard
notices this and immediately throws on
his helmet knowing that he might have to
throw down and he does remind him of
where he is by holding his sword out in
front of him forcing damon to stop
moving but then damon does what he does
best in one moment he dishonors viserys
then in the next moment he lifts him
back up by kneeling in front of him and
offering his crown now it's nowhere near
as nice as the one viserys is already
wearing his is made of gold whereas
demons is made of what looks like
driftwood another thing i love about
this moment is how damon threw down his
weapon and said add it to the throne
it reminded me of sir barristan selmy
when he did the same thing to joffrey
added to the chair
here boy
melted down and added to the others
you can see that viserys doesn't want to
ignore what he's done but at the end of
the day he does love his brother so he
embraces him in front of everyone
letting them know everything is fine one
thing we know about viserys is he is
worried about what everyone else thinks
although he is angry at his brother he
doesn't want to fight with him in front
of everyone else it's a big reason why
viserys doesn't name aegon has his heir
it's not only because he loves his
daughter and wants to stand beside her
it's also because he knows how that will
look in the eyes of everyone else he
actually says this right to ronera later
in the episode he knows if he makes egg
on his hair now after already naming
renera everyone will know he must be
having serious issues with his daughter
he doesn't want the whole realm to know
that his family unit is disintegrating
all around him in the following scene
viserys holds a nice little get-together
for his brother's arrival out in the
backyard as you can see they have the
beer sitting on ice the lore commander
of the kingsguard is overlooking the
burgers and hot dogs on the grill and
sir kristin cole has the football game
on the big screen everyone is having fun
especially damon who sets his sights on
viserys's daughter ronero this is when
he ultimately decides he will want to
have a little fun with his brother's
daughter once the lights go out what i
really love about the scene is how we
were finally given more insight into
viserys and alison's relationship we now
know for a fact just how unhappy allison
really is i like what they've decided to
do with her character they've made her
more sympathetic which will make their
relationship dynamics even more
interesting once ronera and alison start
fighting over the iron throne this might
allow for there to be likable characters
on either side making our investments in
them and our emotional connections to
them even richer i was worried that they
might make alison a villain but they
haven't done that yet as we've seen she
still does love renera and wants what is
best for her so far we see that she's
not driven by the intoxication of the
iron throne i also like how we went back
and forth from renera and allison's
scenes later on we see just how
different their lives are now alison is
stuck having all these babies in a
relationship she really doesn't want to
be in meanwhile renera is out having the
time of her life it was a sad sight to
see viserys who is getting old and
washed up get on top of alison during
their sex scene many would think that
alison might have a great life because
she's married to the king and living
inside of this big-ass castle but we see
her life actually sucks she's alone and
isolated on most of her days this isn't
the life she wanted to live and i
genuinely do feel bad for her i don't
blame her for feeling that way either i
know i would hate living that life now
with that being said we do also see that
she does care for viserys as well we see
that she does help him when he's bathing
and she also offers good advice when
needed this is great because it shows
alison isn't one-dimensional at all then
like many of us assumed damon has
rhaenyra sneak out of the red keep to
join him in his nighttime festivities in
the heart of the city he shows her what
the nightlife is really like once again
this is damon's way of getting revenge
on his brother viserys damon knows how
this will affect ronera's value in the
eyes of the lords of westeros if she
loses her virginity in fact she doesn't
even have to lose it the mere mention of
it or the thought of it alone will make
suitors look elsewhere for a match so he
knows exactly what this will do to
ronera's name another scene that was
very reminiscent of game of thrones was
when renera saw the actors up on stage
many years ago we saw that arya was in
the same shoes when she saw how everyone
felt about her father and sister
what's happened even he brought you here
ned stark because you're the brightest
fellow in the land
someone in the city even called renera a
boy which also reminded me of arya
rhaenyra now gets a glimpse of what
everyone thinks about her and her little
brother aegon in this scene she says she
doesn't care what they think however
damon reminds her that she better if she
ever wants to rule over them this is
actually foreshadowing something that
will happen in the final season of the
show i won't say what that is right now
but let's just say the citizens of
king's landing will do something crazy
he then brings her inside a brothel
letting her see everyone having sex he
even begins seducing renera himself but
suddenly stops soon after she starts
enjoying it once again like in the first
episode it seems as if damon's little
dragon won't fly he might want to find
himself a maester to administer a blue
chew now during the inside the episode
feature the director basically said
damon stopped because he lost control of
the situation he doesn't like it once
rhaenyra starts fully embracing the
moment in a sense he wanted her to
follow his lead then it's not long
before we see one of the little birds
notice who's there among them we now see
how long the capital has been using this
system of little birds running messages
back and forth from the inner city in
the red key
i'll speak to a singularly bad idea do
you see that boy there
one of varys little birds
the spider has taken a great interest in
your comings and goings
as a way of getting back at damon his
former mistress lady massaria or the
white worm ratted him out to the hand of
the king she's the one who had the
message sent to serato hightower
informing him of damon and rinera's
extracurricular activities lady massaria
does that as a way of getting back at
damon for the little stun he did on
dragonstone when he said she was about
to be his wife and have their son that
was only another one of his ways at
getting a reaction out of viserys
now serato will have the information he
needs to really shake things up inside
of the castle as rainier goes back
inside sir christian cole was wondering
how the hell she snuck out he'd been
standing there as a century all night
yet somehow she walked right by him now
that rhaenyra is all hot and bothered
she sets her sights on sir kristen cole
mostly because he's right there but also
because they now have a great
relationship you have to remember by now
he has been raniera's guard for several
years they know each other very well and
she's had her eyes on him since they
first met in episode one now i was
wondering if sir kristen cole was
actually gonna go through with this i
wasn't so sure he would break his vows
so soon i don't think ronero fully
understands or maybe even considers what
is at stake for him he's meant to be
there to watch her back not blow it out
if vasaris found out he took his
daughter's maidenhood not only could he
lose his job but he could also lose his
damn head i thought he might reject her
at first but nope he dove right in head
first now was it just me or did renera
already seem like she knew what she was
doing i know she did just watch everyone
have sex in the brothel but damn she was
already looking like a seasoned veteran
three minutes ago she was a virgin then
the next thing sir krista knows she's
doing the reverse dragon on a headstand
on the following day sir snitch a lot
serato hightower decides what he must do
next he actually gathers himself for a
moment before informing viserys he knows
deep down this will not only affect
damon and renera but this will affect
his relationship with viserys as well
he knows he's about to drop a bombshell
accusing his daughter of some foul [ __ ]
with that being said serato says here
goes nothing and relays the information
anyway and viserys immediately denies it
this reminded me of when cersei went to
her father and revealed her incestuous
relationship with jaime
[Music]
this is a lie
you have been lied to
what
everything they say is true about jamie
and me no your legacy is a lie
i don't believe you
they're always in denial at first
although this shouldn't be that hard to
believe for viserys since this is sort
of normal for his family i mean hell
even allison said the same thing to
renera in the godswood accusation
is it
you targaryens do have queer customs
what i really love about the scene is
how viserys finally calls out serato for
his over-ambition he knows serato hasn't
taken his eyes off that iron throne ever
since aegon was born and he knows it's
in serato's nature to do everything he
can to move aegon one step closer to
taking the iron throne for himself he
assumes that serado was salivating at
the thought of snitching on renero it's
not long before serado realizes he might
have overextended on this one because it
does eventually blow up in his face
later in the episode alison overhears
everything and she's a little
disappointed after hearing her father
tell on roniro she immediately goes
outside and lets raniera know there are
whispers within the red key your secret
is out ranira lies right to her face and
says damon never laid a finger on her
but we all saw what happened and now it
doesn't really matter what happened
because viceros is already furious
regardless of the fact he has daemon
dragged into the great hall just to have
his ass thrown back out of the city
again damon must leave at once and go
back to his wife in the veil i actually
have a very interesting video i want to
make about damon and his wife in the
veil i don't want to say exactly what it
is just yet but i think most of you will
like it if you actually watch it i will
be releasing that in a few days so keep
your eyes open for the damon video
before damon is thrown out of the house
like dj jazzy jeff he reveals what he
really wants he lets viserys know he
wants renera all for himself and again
this is foreshadowing something that
will happen down the road
although he may never say it out loud
let's be honest damon has his eye set on
the iron throne as well he might not
want it as bad as serado but he can't
ignore it either
marrying rhaenyra would set him up
nicely since viserys won't name him as
his heir
damon has to be thinking if i can't have
it for myself he can at least be sitting
next to the woman who does viserys on
the other hand says i don't think so i
already gave renera the option of
finding her own husband but she's ruined
that thanks to you
now viserys will make the decision for
her now renera must marry sir lane or
velaryon not only will this help smooth
things over with the sea snake but this
will also help strengthen rhaenyra and
house targaryen's footing in westeros
the biggest houses will be united once
again
this is the match that does make the
most sense
viserys has to remind her again that she
must get married and begin having her
own heirs she must further the line
because eventually the winds in the
north will rise and move south to
extinguish life as they know it rhaenyra
is reminded of what aegon once feared
one day the white walkers will move
south and they will need a targaryen on
the iron throne to unite westeros in
order to stop them she does understand
this but it seems like she doesn't
really care either way she does finally
agree to marry sir lane or velaryon
under one condition she won serato
hightower gone
he is one of the massive obstacles in
our way of getting what is rightfully
hers viserys agrees and does just that
viserys doesn't beat around the bush
either he lets him know exactly why he's
removing him from the office he doesn't
like how serato is operating now that
his daughter and grandson are so close
to having the iron throne once he's gone
he knows serato won't do the right thing
by making sure rhaenyra ascends the iron
throne like he wants at the end of the
day he has lost faith in his hand he
doesn't like how his motivations are
starting to blur the lines of duty and
ambition so in order to get otto's
forceful hand out of the mix he must
send his ass back to old town on the
next thing smoking when viserys removes
his hand of the king badge serado looks
genuinely broken inside he looks
shattered and it was wonderfully done
like i said at the beginning of the
video this episode was incredible it's
like everything has been shaken up and
scattered to the wind
i think we're now finally starting to
see everyone play the game of thrones
there's backstabbings betrayals marriage
alliances revenge seekers sex workers
little birds and everything else that
makes game of thrones so great i for one
cannot wait to see the next episode and
by the looks of the new trailer it
doesn't seem like things will be slowing
down either make sure you subscribe so
you can see all of my new videos i have
been making 5 new videos every week so
you know there's a lot more heading your
way as always i want to thank everyone
for watching this video i hope all of
you have a great day i will see you
again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you